arrêtons tu connu une réussite
exceptionnelle a débarqué à paris tu
habites est en 14e moment qu'à ses tous
rue de l'ouest
tout allait déchiré affiche les piques
du peigne est derrière et puis tu te
servait comme ça pour tout fluhr des
vallonnements de la fiche c'est à dicter
le très pop art explique un peu comment
tout ça s'est passé parce que les gens
se demandent toujours comment on peut
gagner cent mille france 150 mille
francs par le tableau en peignant o'dowd
affiche qu'on va arracher la nuit j'ai
dû faire les premières affiches
arrachées et commencer à les organiser
comme ça de façon de façon la plus
pertinente dans mon esprit tout à fait à
la fin 81 à noël quoi je connaissais
ville clé déjà oui alors par contre bien
sûr je connaissais tous les nouveaux
rallyes tous échoué
évidemment les premières personnes un
peu
un peu professionnel j'ai rencontré
mondial nous réalisons chose tout est en
fait c'est étonnant parce que c'est
peut-être une des rares choses qu'à
cette époque j'ai pas du tout regardé
bien c'est une chose qui me faisait pas
travailler le regard des avis l'aigle et
ouais et l'affichent d'ailleurs en fait
je sais plus je parlais avec avec une
personne de sa à cette époque et en fait
on avait convenu il fait que je
commençais à travailler là où le à
rethel c'est à dire qu'il travaillait
effectivement les effets du poster et
tout le site et les affiches déchirées
de face voilà tout au tout caractère
sociologique témoignages avoue l'avoir
alors que moi c'est une chose que j'ai
absolument jamais utilisé juste utiliser
simplement un support qui en fait à
l'époque une sorte de raccourci une
façon très simple de récupérer toutes
les qualités qu'avaient les différents
supports je travaillais à dire les
cartons les les tissus imprimés les deux
choses très variées comme ça qu'ils
étaient là réunis dans un seul support
si tu étais pas jean charles blé quel
point tu voudrais être bien au sûrement
pas un an avant non c'est picasso jour
il s'est quand même des adeptes du
collage et du bricolage non oui oui nos
bons j'ai plein de m
je plains de familiarité avec la
peinture et avec un vrai calvaire aux
auteurs mais si si je vais à être
quelqu'un d'autre
ouais sur le mode imaginer un vrai en
temps je crois pas que
d'être peint que a eu de quoi sur les
tas de choses beaucoup plus
extraordinaire que peintre je peux faire
un tableau comme ça c'est comme pour moi
un peintre qui réussit bien évidemment
c'est comme quelqu'un qui peint des
billets de banque situer non je veux
dire c'est bon c'est une chose que
j'adore une ville dort et c'est vrai que
les modèles qui sont des sachets toi tu
es tranquille temps en temps tu vas
avance donc c'est pas mal quand même non
tu tout ça est très bien mais mes dents
dans l'imaginaire moi j'ai jamais eu le
sentiment que c'est une chose
extraordinaire
c'est peut-être pour ça que tu réussis
finalement tu mets quand même temps a
comparé un tableau où sa dépouille à
aucune règle n'y a pas de gros je sais
pas je suis fait le total et tu divises
par le nombre de tableaux si tu veux non
je ne sais pas je sais combien j'ai fait
tableau par exemple combien je suis
actuellement je dois pouvoir faire à peu
près quelque chose comme 20 ou 30
tableaux c'est ce que j'appelle une
saison nba cette saison une saison cdu
c'est une année en fait un bébé auquel
je découpe comme ça ça ne sera pas du
parc tout genre presque presque tous là
mais tout du rock'n'roll de la musique
baroque ou du moins quand j'ai dû
reviendra le sésame par exemple ça peut
être du maine de exprime sous
le dos alidor soci t néo psychédélique
hippie atti pu faire un maillage
picardie qui est allé au lycée palois
nous [ __ ] des outils plus tard 17
heures sous le car les lausannois
avaient dégradé grand copain alors on
l'a dit ça vaut à peu près 300 mille
cent cinquante mille à tavaux de blé
maintenant oui oui des choses comme ça
sont de 100 à 200 milles vachement bien
alors où on vit bien fade aujourd'hui on
vit bien ou bien parce que les matières
premières je veux dire en plus toi c'est
pas trop cher ou bien et tu vas aller
piquer ou ses affiches derrière les
quelques peintres dans la rue tu te fais
pas choqué par les flics n'ont jamais eu
de problèmes comme ça c'est s'exhale pas
pourquoi parce que tu vers les mois et
coûter cher
tout ce que je fais c'est de l'art parce
que je suis un artiste non non sinon je
crois que ça n'intéresse pas j'ai jamais
vu personne c'est auprès de gérald et
puis bon je travaille avec des affiches
sauvages comme ça mais chose qu'on
trouve dans les initiales de chantier
des cheveux et qui je crois je crois
devrait être la fête on n'a pas le droit
de coller les affiches n'importe où ah
oui alors les arracher de force tout
salut public en fait ça sert à quoi la
peinture à ton avis salez les tableaux
réalisés des oeuvres 1,7 à quoi ça sert
ouais ça sert à comprendre le monde pour
moi
on peut les voir ôter table en ce moment
à la galerie yvon lambert l'a dit
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu